it's great to welcome back to the
program today richard wolff who is of
course professor
emeritus of economics at my
undergraduate alma mater the university
of massachusetts currently a visiting
professor at the
new school university in new york city
the latest book
called understanding marxism is
available
all of the normal places including in
digital form
uh professor wolff great to have you on
again glad to be here david really am
so let's start digging into some of the
ideas that we are seeing put forward by
the
2020 democratic challengers on the one
hand we've sort of seen the
mainstreaming of
some ideas that even as recently as four
years ago were considered relatively
niche and left including
a wealth tax including
medicare for all in a sort of more
serious and particular way
what's your overall sense of this shift
and do you think that there is
any policy in particular that goes far
enough in terms of the type of systemic
change that may be needed or are we
really still talking about
sort of band-aids and fixing things
around the edges
well i basically think to get to the
core of your question
that we are still seeing the vast
preponderance of proposals
uh from the democratic contenders
those are band-aids that's right those
are the attempt
uh to see honestly and certainly better
than the republicans can manage
what the failures and flaws and problems
of our economic and political system are
but i do think it's still early in the
process
of facing up to all of it so that they
are mostly
uh band-aids they are mostly attempts
to take what we already have some of and
make it more
comprehensive make it more generous
and hope against hope really that these
adjustments will somehow be adequate
what i do find remarkable and i see it
in the shifting over
to medicare for all and taxing the
wealth there is the beginning of an
understanding that these band-aids
have to go further than one used to
think band-aids
had to go that it wasn't just a little
tweaking
of the tax rates and so forth but
something as fundamental
as a imposing attacks on wealth
itself in the form of stocks and bonds
which this country has avoided doing
uh for most of its history so it is
a recognition that we need more and yet
a hope
that relatively modest things
will be sufficient to what
to change what's going on i think that's
the real
really interesting thing that capitalism
in america
is now produced such an extreme
level of inequality such an extreme
experience
of capitalism's instability the crash of
2008
the 10 years we've just lost trying
quote unquote to recover from it
the fact that the entire financial
community knows
that either this year or next year we're
going to have a recession
and who knows how bad this one will be
all of this
roiling of the realities we live in
is pushing our politics on the right
over toward mr trump and all that he
represents
but on the left in the directions that
your question
raises i saw a critique of
uh that you you were involved in in some
way shape or form i forget exactly on
what show
related to the idea of universal basic
income sort of in the mode that
andrew yang has been proposing it and
i've talked about this a lot including
with him and i have some problems with
the particulars but
to sort of paraphrase and i hope i'm
doing it correctly
one of your more general criticisms was
that giving people a thousand dollars a
month
is not going to solve a lot of the
structural issues that exist regarding
inequality regarding the relationship
between
most workers and their employers etc etc
and i thought that that was a good
critique but
i wondered couldn't the same opposition
be cited
against food stamps against wic etc etc
and it doesn't strike me as a reason
not to do it as long as we sort of
recognize
its limitations so to speak so i guess
to clarify
are you against something like universal
basic income
period like are you against doing it or
is it merely that you want to make sure
that we understand that it's not
structurally changing the problems of
the system
it's mostly the latter i don't oppose
doing these things
any more than i oppose you know giving
welfare to to people who
are denied a job but because
the the the liberal part of american
politics
has long ago given up the critique
of the structure the notion of basic
change
the whole debate of the 20th century
about capitalism versus socialism which
by the way is coming back now
but but because the liberals gave up on
it people like me
have to hammer at the inadequacy of
these
band-aids lest the idea be
that we either have no band-aid or we
have a band-aid
but that something beyond the band-aid
is somehow unthinkable
or undiscussable so i want to point out
that for example if you give everybody a
guaranteed basic
income but some people go to work and
have a job
and earn way more than all of that
you're just
inviting what our own history shows us
which is sooner or later the people who
work
for an in uh living will be how shall i
put it politely
helped to see the people who get the
guaranteed income
as in some sense living off the taxes
they pay
and therefore the tension between the
employed and the unemployed
that has always dogged capitalism will
simply resurface
in an adjusted form around the question
of a basic income therefore i would much
rather
face the reality which is if we have
technological change
that makes it possible for fewer people
to be more productive than they used to
be so that instead of needing a hundred
workers
to make something we only need 50. we
had
we can cut the labor cost in half
capitalism solves that problem in a
particular way
it fires half the people right why
because
then you can produce the same amount
with half the people
sell it let's presume for simplicity at
the same price
and what you get as revenue you now
don't have to pay half the workers you
used to
you keep that money as your profit which
is why the technological
change attracts you in the first place
but that's the capitalist answer
but it ought to be ours why because the
alternative way of handling
a doubling in productivity which is what
we've just discussed
would be to give everybody half the
amount of hours
per day to work that way everybody keeps
their job
everybody keeps their income what the
benefit of technology
is what we've really always promised
people namely
leisure and in a society not driven by
profit
that the technology would be advanced
because the gain
is to the majority in more leisure
rather than the gain to a minority
in the way of more profit these are the
questions that are structural and basic
and these are the ones that still remain
a bit
too scary for virtually all of the
candidates in the democratic party
to get a hold of yeah i actually did a
commentary yesterday about the latest
jobs numbers and i said it's fine to
talk about
75 000 versus the expected number it's
fine to talk about 0.2
wage growth versus 0.5 but fundamentally
none of this stuff is actually
addressing
uh these incoming and growing issues of
the relationship of humans to work and
my analysis of the hundred employees
versus 50
due to the technological change has been
and i wonder if you agree with it
that the pure free market capitalist
sort of
reception of that technological change
that allows you to double productivity
would be you fire half the workers and
that's also bad
for other elements of the economy
because now you have 50 workers that no
longer have money with which to buy
things
from other businesses the pure socialist
solution might be well we've socialized
ownership of the company to begin with
so the workers share in all the gains
now here's where i wonder if we disagree
the social democracy solution might be
the business owners are entitled to some
piece
of that productivity gain whereas some
significant portion
would be divided up by the workers is
that fair is that pie in the sky
no i think that's a perfectly reasonable
step
i mean it assumes something namely that
the owners
are in some sense different from the
people who are
working there yes if you really change
the system
that difference would disappear but
let's cut keep it for a while let's
assume
that there are owners or capitalists on
the one hand and workers on the other
it would be an enormous step forward i
would agree
to have a discussion in which the
question is raised
okay we now have a technical advance we
can install that here in the business we
have
and that gives us what it gives us a
choice
we can either use all of it for profit
and fire half the workers
or we can use none of it for profit
and give all the workers basically a
half-time employment situation
at the same wage or and this is simple
arithmetic
we can split the difference we can have
a conversation
a discussion maybe a vote as to what
portion of the gains from a
technological
advance are given to workers in the form
of leisure versus employers
in the form of profits that already
would be a level of the democratization
of the workplace
which is what i stress anyway would be a
major
step forward and by the way while this
is a revolutionary
idea here in the united states right
social democracies in europe
this is not a new idea this is in fact
what goes on in germany and france and
italy
unions often are bargaining with
employers
on precisely how to divide
technical and other kinds of advances in
terms of
sharing in a sense in the benefits it's
not revolutionary
it's not challenging the private
ownership of
the industries and the empire and the
enterprises
but it is saying that what happens with
an advance of technology
is something that has to be discussed
and worked out
like everything else about the workplace
and not something simply
to be determined to the advantage of one
side and the exclusion of participation
on the other
well that gets me to something else i
want to hear your thoughts on
which is that there's a very specific
and productive i think debate to be had
about
capitalism versus socialism social
democracy versus unregulated capitalism
etc
but are you concerned about what i have
seen
as sort of some confusion between social
democracy
and socialism i've done a number of
segments where i'm saying
if we even really want to seriously have
this debate we have to make sure that
we're calling things what they are and
socialism where the means of production
is socialized is different
than something like the swedish system
or the danish system which is a
capitalist system that says we are going
to use
more of the government revenue to ensure
that the standard of living doesn't go
below a certain level
is that an academic distinction or is
that a serious distinction that we need
to understand to really talk about this
stuff
i could not be more 100 the latter and
not the former in other words
this is not academic or abstract
or nitpicking or anything like that this
is of the essence
and that's part of our our backwardness
here in the united states
for a half a century after after the end
of world war
ii socialism communism marxism
all of that was prescribed it was
declared
traitorous it was declared evil it was
whatever you want and people were good
americans who kept away from it
didn't think about it didn't read about
it didn't debate about it
nothing and now that capitalism has
shown itself
to need basic change to an awful lot of
people for whom it isn't working
real well there's a process of
rediscovery
and that's all to the good but in that
process you are right
the confusion and the misuse of language
and the naming of things that really
ought
to be named that way because a hundred
years of literature
and a debate uh have clarified these
differences
but americans are just learning let me
give you an example
two weeks ago i was invited and i did it
to be on the town hall of the fox
television system for an hour yes
answering questions from a live audience
uh debating by the way lou dobbs and
neil cavuto and
all of those people sitting next to me
uh herman cain
the candidate for president so that we
had a debate it was capitalism versus
socialism
and there on display was this arresting
fudge of words and ideas
in which the same word socialism was
applied
to sweden to italy to china
to russia to venezuela i mean the chaos
and confusion
that is being sown now partly on the
other side they want to lump all of
these things together
right i understand that but if you're
interested in these things
as real options for a society in
difficulty which i am
and many americans are that has to be
clarified
and i think it's very good even if it's
difficult that you begin to say look
this is social democracy or this is
democratic socialism
this is something else to which we can
give a variety of names that have been
used
but we have to begin clarifying this so
we can have
the conversation and the political
action
uh focused on what it is we actually
want
well that's good it makes me feel better
that i haven't been wasting my time with
those
uh with those segments we've been
speaking with economist richard wolff
the new book is called understanding
marxism it's available everywhere you
would imagine
books are available uh professor wolf
always great to talk to you
great to talk to you david and hope we
can do it again soon